problem with covid is that you
essentially you're doing
a risk calculation and the calculus of
risk
of course concerns the disease but it's
got also to concern
the economy the social and the health
impacts of the shutdown
so the science will only take you so far
and it's like
you know arguments over two meters one
meter
distancing i mean in the end these are
political judgments that you've got to
make
so i don't i don't regard this as you
know you either follow the science or
the politics
the scientists can tell you what they
know um
but sometimes what they know by the way
is not that clear
but in the end you're gonna have to make
a political judgment about these things
and you're all the time i mean every
single government around the world
is doing a risk calculus and the most
important thing i think is to to
to engage people since this is something
that everyone's concerned with right
every single person wants to know about
this
the best thing is to is to explain that
risk calculus
and take people into your
confidence in explaining why these are
difficult judgments in the end and the
science only takes you so far
the paradox of politics is that you
begin at your
least capable and most popular and you
end
at your least popular and most capable
so by the time you
had long experience of government it's
like anything else but people never
treat politics like this
you know the longer you go on the more
experience you get
and what you realize when it comes to
something like this is
you really have to to reorganize
government
when you're facing something as
overwhelming as this
and you have to broaden the skill base
of the people taking the decisions
so this is why you know in this
situation
by the end of my time maybe not at the
beginning of my time but by the end of
it i would have been
pulling in people from every walk of
life that could help
bring different skills knowledge
experience
uh creativity to dealing with this and i
just think it's a very difficult thing
for governments to do because
what what what the government system i
always say this about our civil service
it actually works really well at a time
of of crisis when the crisis
is just an event that you have to react
to
what it's less good at is is when
the crisis calls over a long period of
time
for skills that it's not surprising the
civil service just don't don't have
but there are people who have those
skills and you've got to pull them into
government
and and get them sat alongside the
politicians
so i think that's really what i would i
would say about this
that's the reason why it's so difficult
i mean it's a really
difficult difficult thing to deal with
but i think we can going forward
we can make sure our economic damage is
a lot less
if there's the right relationship
between the business sector
and government where i think there needs
to be a a really
integrated approach where your your
your the politicians really understand
what the problems of ordinary businesses
i mean small as well as large you're
gonna faces themselves
and how you help overcome them all of
those people in
in government will be working really
hard on this i mean you know they're not
they'll be deeply committed to trying to
get this right
i think though whereas i think in the
first couple of months
of the disease virtually
everything is excusable because you're
doing it in hindsight you're saying well
you
should have locked down earlier and so
on and obviously there'll be
you know uh people investigate and
interrogate that
i think what is what is not excusable
now
is not with the knowledge we now have to
realize
that you've got to put in place
everything that it can ensure
that if there is a resurgence in the
autumn of winter
then you're then fully prepared because
that is the
if you manage to come if we manage to
come through this crisis
through the summer and it it dies away
most governments around the world that
i'm talking
about are becoming i would say
mildly not strongly mildly more
optimistic
okay may not look like that but actually
internal to the people i'm talking to in
the us and europe
in the developing world even they're
getting
more optimistic if i was in government
right now
though i would be saying look is it
that we're more optimistic because the
lockdown's been so savage we're bound to
have a real impact on the disease
is it that the summer months mean that
the disease
is less virulent um
and i would conclude that i couldn't be
sure
and therefore it may be that we don't
get a resurgence in autumn and winter in
which case
the economies will will come back in a
much stronger way
but if for any reason it turns out that
you do get a resurgence
then that's when you're going to have a
serious serious problem
because i think to go back into lockdown
is going to be
really tough and you just think of the
lockdown and how it's been and living
through this
and you know let's let's be sort of
frank to think about it not as
politicians or
journalists as people it's been a lot
easier because
the days are longer the weather's been
better
you know it's not such a hardship to
lock down
when when you know in the summer months
you think of locking down in november
and december
it's going to be really awful so that's
why i think that
whatever criticism you can make of the
past in relation to the government's
handling of this
i'm not so interested in that because
one thing is nothing we can do about it
what i really do think is important is
to put in place the containment
infrastructure
that means if you do for any reason get
a resurgence
in the winter then you've got such a
big operation in place to handle it that
you're
able to handle it without going back
into the sort of severe lockdown we've
had in these last weeks